[Music]
good morning everyone thanks for joining
us today
my name is Adrian Roos I'm a software
engineer on the android framework team
i'm Andriy I'm also a software engineer
on Android frameworks and then work on a
multi display hi I'm Jason from Samsung
mobile I'm engineering director so by
now I'm sure you've all seen the
announcement that we are partnering with
Samsung to make foldables a thing on
Android and today we're driving a bit
deeper into what that means and what
we're doing to support you developers
with targeting foldable devices and
similar form factors and cheese zone is
here to talk a bit more about what
Samsung is doing and share more
information about their device so with
that I'm gonna hand it over to cheek
soon okay thanks thank you so again I'm
Jason from Samsung mobile and I'm gonna
talk about the new form factor device
which you actually announced yesterday
at the Samsung developer conference in
Moscone Center okay so I will cover more
information about the device itself and
also we'll talk about the experience the
new foldable device will bring to the
users we all know that the smart phone
has been providing new experiences for
the last 10 years and it actually
changed the way people think act and
also communicate additionally it also
opened up a lot of a lot of new
opportunities for the developers now we
believe a foldable phone is one of the
next game changers which will provide a
very unique experience to the users and
also new opportunities for the
developers to drive innovations okay so
now let's talk about the first Samsung
affordable phone
the first is Samsung foldable phone is
design to be multi display with two
screens and also supports a multi active
window for better experience usually
experience so let's take her first to
look at the what the actual
configuration of the display on the
device looks like so this is the main
display when the device is unfolded the
main display is large enough to provide
a very unique experience with just more
surface area it provides the experience
becomes richer and more immersive the
experience was hardly achievable even
from the existing largest screen
smartphones in addition to the richer
and immersive experience from a single
largest screen true multitasking will
become also available to utilize this
large screen with up to three our multi
active windows when the phone is
actually folded we still have very
useful and portable cover display to use
in this mode the experience is very
similar to your daily or smartphone use
but compared to the main display the
experience is more to be focused in
handy and quick interaction to actually
leverage it a small screen so having
said that here are the some numbers that
you may be interested in this is the
specs and the dimensions of the actual
screens so four point five eight inch
color display provides twenty one to
nine HD Plus resolution with the 420 TPI
as current density and 320 dpi smallest
wisk 7.3 inch main display supports 4.2
the three qxga plus resolution
with the same 420 DPI screen density
with 585 DPS smallest ways these are the
numbers um may need to know now I will
show you some expected user experience
with some examples so comparing the user
experience between the existing
smartphone and foldable main display the
foldable this foldable phone can
actually allocate wider and larger
display access to the application and it
actually enables the contents on the
screen to be richer and more detailed as
you can see from this screen on the
cover screen when device is folded I
said the experience can be optimized to
provide the quick and easy access and
interaction while the devices are still
fully functional like a normal
smartphone access to the quick panel or
notification or call or messaging are
good examples to highlight the best to
use recover display we know that you may
not want to just unfold your phone to
take an incoming call while the cover
display and main display it shown
provides there all its own a very unique
experience by itself the experiences
between them are not separate nor
disconnected rather the user experience
between that this place is very
continuous and connected seamlessly
as an example if we want to search for
the location of Moscone Center from a
map you can do that with your phone
folded however if you've unfold your
phone the application still continues to
run even more unfolding the phone
actually provide more information with
more visual clues like a water nearby
and what's the location to the other
a point of interest using the gallery
app is similar the app experience
continues between the folded mode and
also unfolded mode multi active windows
for multitasking is also one of the key
features of the foldable phone so while
watching a YouTube video if we want to
browse the website you can just open up
browse open a browser and browse the web
site while your videos to keep playing
moreover if your friends actually sends
a message and the message a pop-up
notification pops up what you can do is
just to grab that message E and drag it
to a third window like this to continue
chatting and browsing while your videos
still keep playing so we have discussed
the expected experience with the new
foldable device so now Adrian from
Google will talk about developer guide
and also some Android platform level
support for to make your applications
best fit for the foldables thanks for
sharing that she soon
so let's talk a bit more about how you
can take advantage of foldables
in your apps and like kind of the
guidelines that we recommend to do so so
first up is screen continuity screen
continuity it's really the concept it's
what we call the concept of continuing
what you're currently doing after you
fold or unfold the device and in the
example here for example you have a you
have a map you're looking at on a folder
device and you would like to see maybe a
bit more about the surroundings of the
place you're looking at so as a user you
unfold the phone and with a continuous
experience you are still looking at the
same place your state is maintained and
the phone can take now a bit more
advantage of the form factor and show
you more about what's going on around
this place and this is actually not
really a new thing in Android right we
still we've had to deal with similar
situations before where things like
screen rotation or changing changing
screen sizes or sorry changing window
sizes in multi window so why should you
care about continuity when you build
your app well users unfold their devices
for a reason and usually that's because
they want to dive deeper into the task
they're currently doing so that really
works best when they are not interrupted
in their experience when doing so and
can continue where they left off before
unfolding so for a satisfying user
experience it's really important that
this works well that seems great now how
do you actually pull this off well as I
said Android is familiar with this and
we've built a configuration change
system to deal with that folding and
unfolding the device will be treated as
a configuration change in the screen
size and screen layout categories and to
support you with that the Android system
by default recreates your activities
when it's in a configuration change
and this has the advantage of taking
care of any layout changes you might
want to make then taking advantage of
the new configuration but it also means
that you as the app are responsible for
restoring the state the user was in
after that activity is recreated to
support it with that we have the unsafe
instance state facility and we're also
introducing a new check back library
called view model to support you with
that alternatively you could also decide
to handle the configuration change
yourself by it just applying it and
adjusting your layout to do that you can
declare that you can handle the
configuration change in your Android
manifest but that means that you'll have
to manually adjust the layout to the new
screen size and new configuration and
for the best experience
make sure to correctly implement
multi-window and to declare your
activity as resizable now next up we're
making some changes to the life cycle in
multi-window you can see the current
behavior on the left and that is that
only the activity that the user last
touched is in the resumed state while
all the others are in the past state
that's a bit confusing to users because
it's not immediately obvious why the why
one activity is a bit more interactive
and by other activists are in a less
interactive state and it's also one more
thing you have to keep in mind as a
developer when you target multi-window
so to make things simpler we're
introducing multi resume mode a multi
resume mode it's pretty simple really
all the activities in multi window that
are at the top and are visible are all
in the resume state now Android piden
ship with this with this behavior
originally and so we're making this an
opt-in behavior in android pi it will
only be applied if both the app
developer opt-in and the device
sure actually implements this feature
according to our spec but note that in
future versions of Android we are
expecting it to we are expecting to make
this behavior the mandatory behavior
across all apps and devices that run on
the next version of Android so let's say
you have an app and want to take
advantage of this simplified life cycle
how do you opt in well again it's pretty
simple you add this one flag to your
Android manifest there's one caveat
though because there are now multiple
activities that could be resumed at the
same time it could also be that it's
more than one activity from your apps
process and so be really cautious around
code that stores the one recent activity
because they might now be more than one
of those and also be cautious around
libraries and frameworks that might make
the same assumptions now with that I'm
gonna hand it back over to andrey who's
gonna talk about multi window multi
display Thank You Adrian so let's talk a
bit more about multi screen devices so
as you know starting with Android Oh an
activity can be launched on a non
default display let's see what it
actually means for your activity first
of all when an activity is on a non
default display it means that the
activity context which is a visible
entity is different from non visual
application context also available from
broadcast receivers and content
providers the context of a visible
entity will be always adjusted for the
display area where it is shown for
example if you use the same API to get
the current display and use different
context types to ask for it you all get
different results the current display
you can get it from the activity and the
application context will always give you
the default display
different contacts also mean different
resources and configurations they will
be automatically updated for you all you
need to do is just to request them from
the correct context usually when you
want to adjust your UX for metrics of
the currently available screen area you
should be using an activity keep in mind
that the user may move your activity
from one screen to another at any point
in most cases you can expect this place
to have different sizes densities and
resolutions this means that an activity
that was mode will probably get a
configuration change as Adrienne has
covered before and if it declared to
handle the change it will be notified
with a new config if not it will be
relaunched to deliver the best possible
experience both for foldable and for
multi display devices we really
encourage you to handle configuration
changes whenever it's possible and if
your app really needs to know what
display this is it is currently on you
can check in on create and on
configuration change these are good
points to do that so what if you want to
take advantage of this additional
screens how do you use them so the first
step is to actually get the list of all
this place that I available in the
system by checking with display manager
the displays will have many different
characteristics so you can check their
flags metrics and state to find the one
that suits your needs for example you
can use you can look for a live screen
to present your media content or filter
out the displays that are currently off
once you have determined what display
you want to use you can launch your
activity there using this activity
options API available in Android all
remember that all existing intent
resolution and launch mode rules still
apply so for example if you want a new
instance of an activity you may want to
use correspondent Flags an Android
manifest to all multiple instances and
use new tasks for this launch sometimes
the system may restrict activity
launches to some certain displays for
example private displays in this case a
call to start an activity will throw a
security
option you can expect this and wrap the
start with strike edge remember that
there are several platforms that
actually have multi display devices
phones with different screen
configurations is just one example that
we have covered today next there is
desktop mode when you connect your phone
to larger screen for improved
productivity or entertainment
another example is Android apps running
on Chrome OS in both of these cases the
apps are usually running in freeform
window in mode and the user expects them
to be freely and smoothly resizable last
but not least is automotive Android
there are maybe many screens in a car
and multiple users may be interacting
with different displays at the same time
for example kids in the backseat may be
playing same or different games while
the driver is using navigation for apps
in general there shouldn't be too many
differences on what platform it's
running on to verify your app behavior
on any Android device running or above
you can create a simulated display
through developer options and launch
your activity there unfortunately at
this moment simulated display does not
handle touch we are working on improving
this experience in the upcoming releases
and we are going to be adding new
developer tools with all this new and
existing platforms you can choose to
simply optimize your app or build some
unique multi-screen experience you can
decide whether you want to support
multiple activity instances test your
app and set corresponding launch modes
don't forget that in this case multiple
activities may be focused and receive
user input at the same time also
consider using the shared source of data
with multiple view models in your app
and take advantage of other architecture
components resdac make 2 engine thanks
so we've talked about what's available
today let's also look a bit more about
we're going to do in the future to
support you with targeting foldables and
multi display devices in the short term
for this place mostly for Android PI
we're working on developer guidelines
and we're going to show you how to best
target foldables and multi display
devices we're also working on a blog
post that's going to go live in the
following days which will have more
information about everything we talked
about and we're also working with
Samsung to release an emulator where you
can develop and test your apps against
configuration configuration change
behaviors and the multi resume behaviors
that their device will is going to have
looking a bit more into the into the
future with future versions of Android
we're implementing support in AOSP for
foldables and multi display devices and
of as part of this we're also going to
improve the ASP emulator so it will have
support for simulating all those
foldable and multi display behaviors as
Andreea also mentioned finally some
pointers on very confined more
information in the following days as I
mentioned we'll have this blog post up
there's also a Samsung developer site
where you will find more information
about Samsung's devices and their
guidelines and for testing your apps the
Samsung emulator will also be available
on their website sometime in q4 ok at
this point I would also like to thank
you for all the amazing experiences you
developers are building for Android and
we're really excited to see what you
will do next and while you will create
next on this new form factor of foldable
devices thank you
[Applause]
[Music]